keeping up with the kardashians  officially wraps production on at season  12 following Kim's Paris robbery ordeal  most of the family celebrated finishing  filming of the latest season on Tuesday  night Khloe Kylie and Kourtney all  shared pics from the rat parties photo  booth posing with scott disick and with  momager Kris Jenner but Kim was nowhere  to be seen a source close to the star  tells ET she's still laying low quote  there is not a big plan in place for her  comeback it's only been a week she is  still staying off the grid and away from  everything Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna  seemingly skipped tuesday's event too  though China did pop up on snapchat  where she revealed her current pregnancy  weight and due date it's november 16  you